do you do you keep track of your yeah
sorry too but like damn it
what what was your recovery last night
when you woke up this morning do you
know it was it was pretty it was all
right that i only done one session
yesterday saw me i got it up for you
know because sometimes it records me
sleep wrongdoing says i woke up at this
time and i know i've woke up area i mean
i've had a sleep area you could change
that but i'm cause i'm just curious
about like you know your last nightmare
is 85
85 is that normal eh that's high 70 the
day before yeah let me go back a bit but
like dude 27 day before i slept really
well
and i don't get it because i'm like i
had some oh yeah you need to change it
from on the sleep you can change it to
get by so i've changed my hands i get by
you've got yours on like the highest one
made it once you said a [ __ ] crazy
amount of sleep what do you mean if you
do this
you buy
it's got three different settings on the
sleep and get by is like the lowest one
just like get by on the amount of sleep
so it has my sleep as light as like i
don't need as much sleep
that's funny you can change it because i
if i still had it on that i'd always be
in bed i was i'm in therapy and the the
therapist goes you know you're just the
get by guy
when you said get by i'm like i want to
just get back
outside
no damn so excited to be putting on a
brand new whoop strap
yeah i mean dude it's a game changer for
my like recovery and health when you're
like training for a ufc fight like are
your levels just off these hearts just
ridiculous in in like a goal behind show
you that that's some of the [ __ ]
that's what's so crazy about the whoops
that when you're doing the right thing
when you're taking care of yourself and
you're eating right like the numbers
actually show you that you're taking
care of yourself my um
some days are you being like five
thousand calories underneath
yeah and what's your strain for a day
like when you're working out for 20 ones
really i mean yeah [ __ ] dude
yeah like do you ever work out so hard
like close to like bedtime that you
can't sleep because your heart's just
jacked no normally i'll be honest i
normally get most of my sessions done in
like the morning in the daytime
i try and get all mine done before
before the night when you say a session
like that that can mean a lot of things
right yeah definitely every morning i go
to the next gen me gym back home on a
scene for two hours first so i'll do ten
ten till twelve out of a spa days on a
spot are going a little bit early and it
pads with only coaches at us this is
when you're not in a camp
yeah um let them in comp
like camp or not camping
when i'm in the pool i'm saying every
day so you train year round whether
you're in a camper yeah even when you've
you've put on all the weight after your
fight you're still yeah it's not saying
like i've seen this one and a half now
in 5 40. around the corner
yeah like even though i'm about 200
pounds still going the same way you're
about 200 pounds yeah dude that's so
crazy i had this idea right because i've
uh
just got addiction [ __ ] issues like
like the first she was drugged
it's like
i i've been i've flooded i've had party
days on what i mean i'm like yeah i've
been bad then then i got into a bit of a
gambling and i was bad with that now
right i think now that's moved on to
food you know what i mean i really no
i'm not messing i genuinely think i'm a
food
i think i've got a little bit i think
i've got a bit of an eating disorder
because of
because of mma
really
cuts out the way cuts die and i just i
really genuinely think i've had a bit of
an eating disorder because at times like
this now i just will see it later
because we're going to watch the ufc
laces ice yeah if there's food in there
you will be like
she's still eating what i mean people
like when they go and eat with me
they're like they're like
visibly shocked
what's your favorite cheat meal
a lot i got asked this all the time and
i can't i can't say one food it's like
because i love that many food love
pizzas burgers wings thai food
chinese food let me ask you advice on
this i just dropped like 30 pounds yeah
and i'm having a hard time cutting 10
pounds
how do you cut weight so fast for a
fight because the face bit is the
easiest bit that's what it's like for me
not everyone says oh these [ __ ] i do
i go up to like
200 pounds last time i start seven weeks
out so
seven weeks out the monday seven weeks
out i was 88.8 kilo last time
basically 89 that's like
196 197 something along them lands and
i was like five weeks later six weeks
like that i was like
78 points something i mean i'd lost like
10 kilo in like five weeks
and then
by fight week i get to like 75 70 76
and then i have to cut the five kilo
which is not
it's nothing to cut 10 11
how do you what are you doing in the
past you've probably definitely seen the
video of me being sick in the cage
vomiting in the cage wow i've never not
seen it about jesus because i still
don't thought everyone's seen that that
went viral years ago i defended me belt
on cage already against juliana rosa
someone who you'll know
um
at defending me bells games it was a
close fight to be honest if it was the
new judging system now i probably would
have lost the fight because it was still
the old judging system i definitely won
the first three rounds with like
controlling but then i gassed bad
because i've done 19 pound overnight
to be 145. 19 pounds overnight yeah
and it was like
it's so funny that when i when i asked
uh on the mike tyson podcast or i said
something about how i asked chuck
liddell has anybody ever donated a pint
of blood to make weight and he says
that's a good idea
wow how much is a pint of blood 16
ounces is a pint so that's a full
[ __ ] pound and then i was thinking
last night i wonder if you could uh take
out the blood and then just put it back
in that's blood open though with it but
it is it yeah that's what that's class
does blood open did you see what
happened to me boy paulo costa the other
day
dude [ __ ] knocked on his door at six
am or seven a.m before his weight flies
away
some [ __ ] tough blood
it's cheeky that looks like
wow happy tongues
i mean he was weighing pretty heavy like
pretty close to his fight right here's
the thing i saw that he made weight
185.5 yeah which is like even like you
know
right i mean it's totally illegal if
it's not a championship bout but he's uh
made weight but the thing was i saw him
on the scale he looked like unhealthy to
like
i don't think he looked up i don't think
he looked bad i mean i love [ __ ]
but i just don't think he's a natural
middleweight it's like have you ever
liked if you found someone pictures from
my weight cuts years ago yeah that's
true too i looked head of a lot like
eyes drawn in my head but like
a gem in our team of lame mistake
mistakes from our past known i mean me
and molly and a few of the older people
in the gym have have done the bad weight
cuts to realize what we need to do so
none of the younger ones do that now
yeah now you look good on your on your
way in no nowadays it's easy not as i
say uh
i'm mentally strong enough to do [ __ ]
25 pounds if i need to
but eleven pounds or not yeah you're
epic man so what i was gonna say is that
i'm a food addict too right like i just
got in real trouble with sugar
and and i i got like fatter than i've
ever been and then i finally just
buckled down and got in a food program
and i thought like i'd lost so much
weight i got like way skinnier but my
[ __ ] scale told me i'm still 179
pounds and i thought there's no [ __ ]
way my scale is wrong i have to buy a
new scale
i gotta buy a new scale so then i
thought last night well [ __ ] we're gonna
be with patty tomorrow and my experience
with them at mike tyson's podcast was
just like he's not the kind of guy that
gets offended or sensitive like he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] and i was like i
want to buy a new scale anyway
so what if i buy a brand new scale on
the way to go meet patty and and see if
he wants to hop on it let's do it right
here i don't give a [ __ ] he says i don't
give a [ __ ] i knew he wouldn't
well you want to film that this is our
way of going for a viral mma [ __ ]
media moment well hold on what do you
think you are right now i'm saying i
didn't eat
i didn't eat that much yesterday to be
honest so i only i had a it was a
[ __ ] big ass portion of the portions
here it's ridiculous yeah it's a big ass
horse
a pad thai big ass porsche and a pad
thai and we had a few stars isn't that
as well but i'll get on these now yeah
you just need to stand on them yep
maybe empty your pockets
these these are a bit weighty these
shorts but they're not that weighty i
took my watch off what do you think you
are
206.6 but he's got clothes on right
there
dude that's like really
cool i mean he was saying dude you're
gonna do that like
yeah you can't ask me to get on a scale
and i was like you know i don't think
i actually i weighed myself before in 5
40. i was 202.
so
play out a bit heavy
well probably you got [ __ ] because that
because like you know i've got clothes
on that these are the bit everyday
shorts but i haven't got nothing really
in me pockets like what i mean and then
but you just ate probably drink water
that counts oh yeah i've drank a little
water
i did i used to like try to like weigh
myself and then like uh yeah like like
actually i say you can't you can't weigh
yourself any other time apart from first
thing in the morning yeah right
if you had to fight it anyway i mean we
don't play ourselves apart from any
other time
as
first thing in the morning but how do
you lose i had that kind of i got on the
scales in the night
like if i had gone on the scales them
scales tonight after we've when the net
and [ __ ] watch the ufc 209 210 easy
yeah what i mean i think that clip was
awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what i've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions which is out september 27th
and if you pre-order it right now you
can get the autographed copy so get on
it man pre-order my book it's not going
to waste your time because i'm proven
dude new york times best seller my first
book's five star rated on amazon and i
have no doubt this one will be two so
get the autographed copy right now by
pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude